the fact is people seem to really
freaking love valorant it offers players
a way more digestible introduction into
the attack fps genre than say
counter-strike and not only that but a
much more vibrant and visually appealing
atmosphere where unique agent abilities
have helped riot distance themselves
from the game's originator i don't
follow cs anymore because it's too
realistic and dark for me nowadays now
that i've played the child against for
so long i cannot take how gritty and
dark cs is but just like most games
valorent is filled with various cosmetic
microtransactions from player cards to
gun skins and even gun buddies players
are able to express themselves in a
number of different ways and in this
case
let me tell you valor and players really
love to express themselves
suffice it to
say there are some real skin fiends out
there my name is you're not justin i'm
in the pursuit of buying every single
skin in valorum and to do that every
single week i'm gonna put a hundred
dollars on my account and buy the skins
that are in my store so you the viewer
can see every single skin and so i can
own every single skin but there's
something odd about valorance weapon
skins in particular
you see for some reason the community is
convinced
that they're paid to win anybody who
tells me the the skins don't
feel different they're drunk they're
playing a different game yeah i think
some skins are pay to win i personally
feel like valentine is pay to win yes
valor is pay to win so why is it that so
many pro players content creators even
casual players all seem to agree that
skins equal wins
hell even valorent's devs are playing
along but
you gotta ask
is there any truth to this ridiculous
claim i mean our skins are pay to win
just make why joy wide make our hitbox
wider no
[Applause]
okay so before we dive into the world of
valor skins please do your boy a favor
like the video subscribe to the channel
turn on notifications
also if you are interested in acquiring
a riot gun buddy be sure to dm my boy
colton on twitter at the only zoltan i
hear he only has like 50 so you got to
get in there hard and you got to get in
there fast
thanks dimitri
all right so let's get to the bottom of
this why is it that ever since valoren's
first official release back in june of
2020 when we first got our hands on the
prime vandal
everyone has been suggesting that the
game's skins
actually make you play better since the
very first gun bundle came out players
have noticed that certain skins just
hit different from prime oney reaver ion
and more recently rgx there is a near
endless list of so-called pay to win
skins invalorant now if you buy the
bundles while they're still in the shop
then you can consider yourself lucky
because
once they're gone it could be months
before you see them again just ask my
dude shaz whose longing for the ion
sheriff became a community-wide meme i
couldn't get the skin for so long that i
wanted it more every time um
there's literally a twitter account made
hashtag has gotten the item sheriff yet
and stuff so like
it built a lot of uh
there's a lot of drama surrounding me
trying to get the ihf every day every
day i check the shop and every day i was
disappointed for nine months now shazzy
isn't alone here many members of the
valorem community are just hopelessly
addicted to buying skins some of them
check their shop at the exact same time
each and every day only to have
disappointment coming crashing down over
them but when that one skin finally
shows up
it is [ __ ] glorious
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so with pay to win cosmetics being such
a point of discussion within the
community we took it upon ourselves to
get to the bottom of things
and we figured who better to ask
than riot themselves we recently spoke
with valrant's producer for premium
content pre-d canola car and the game's
associate art director sean moreno to
get a better idea of how a skin bundle
is built from the ground up
and here's what they had to say there's
a lot of different ways we uh come up
with different skin ideas um the kind of
exciting one that i think people will
find really interesting is like getting
into a room and everyone writes down
like sticky notes of like different
ideas and looks at different art books
and looks at the internet put all the
stickies up on the wall and then we vote
on which ones we think are cool and then
uh if you're really passionate about an
idea you claim it as your own and then
you put together this like five minute
presentation of like why we must make
the skin why players will love it why is
exciting what features would exist and
then based on that we kind of decide
will be the right thing to make okay so
now we know how these bundles get from
point a to point b but we wanted to ask
pros content creators even casters
why it is they feel that certain bundles
give an added advantage
and some of them
couldn't really explain it the protocol
bundle that just came out i bought it
immediately and
i pretty much like already got to like a
radiant i'm like radiant
78 or something like i was literally
winning games that i had no business
winning like we we would be clutching
one like 1v5s and it's just it just
doesn't make sense it's almost as if
like games are easier but for others
there was a pretty
common theme underlying their answers no
sounds
that's where it is having those sick
sound effects having those sick
finishers having those sick uh kill
sounds
and the bullets and everything
is huge for me the sound is the biggest
thing for me audio seems to be the
number one thing on people's minds when
they pick up a skin for the first time
sure there can be fun visual effects
associated with your weapon and some
tracers might be easier to see than
others but if it doesn't sound sick
it's not up to snuff
so how does ride ensure that they're not
creating skins that sort of accidentally
put players at a disadvantage
well that's where the game's associate
art director sean helped provide some
insight i mean performance competitive
integrity and
like just how how visually appealing it
like all that stuff tying together is
like always the thing that we're trying
to balance
the number one thing that we always like
come back to at the end and just say
like is this
is this where it needs to be is like the
audio
right like firing sounds or equip sounds
like if it if there's something off
about that we're usually tuning that up
to the very end um
just because it's the thing that can
cause like the biggest impact for
someone not wanting to use a skin or
wanting to right if they really like it
but we just want to make sure that
that's really balanced out now although
riot has made it explicitly clear that
none of the skins in valorant are
actually pay to win and we're obviously
not suggesting that they are
there is something to be said for the
different kill sounds in the game some
players hear the sound of a double kill
or a triple kill and eventually
want to push to hear the sweet sound of
an ace if you ask me the e minor scale
that builds with every kill is the best
thing about valorant and has been around
since the beta
i swear on my life i cannot aim with
dude i feel like sometimes i'm not with
the the default skins but
i think it's a mental thing with the
noises i swear the noises make me aim
differently because like when i get a
kill with the prime versus the default
skin i feel like the detail skin is so
like
you know what i'm saying like it's like
boring it's like it doesn't help me like
but like when i shoot with like the
primer like with the reaver like
anything with noises it stimulates my
brain and gets me going like 2000 miles
per hour realistically in reality
valor is technically not pay-to-win
um
theoretically anything you can do with
one skin you can pull off
with the default skin but does it sound
cool though like in your brain in my
brain there's something
psych like there's some neurons firing
when it hears the prime
uh vandal just going pew pew pew like
that makes me want to just lock in dial
in and shoot more right it's on it's
almost synonymous to like your teammate
going nice after a sick kill it makes
you want to dial in and go for more of
course there have been cases in other
games where skins actually have given
players an unfair advantage but the list
is pretty long and inexhaustible so to
help us expunge it i'm gonna bring in my
boy colton and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about so in case
it wasn't obvious i can't get you a riot
gun buddy but still hit my twitter
because the fact that dimitri is the
only verified member on the crack team
is honestly a tragedy
man what did i do in a past life to get
myself roped into yet another script
where i'm forced to talk about valorant
guns
i will admit the last one ended up being
pretty interesting and i learned a lot
about valerian's neck code so if you
want to know more about how your bullets
go from the barrel of your prime vandal
to the wall beside your opponent's head
then you should check out our episode on
the phantom versus the vandal and not to
double up on the shameless plugs but we
actually did an entire top 10 episode
looking at the most notorious banned
skins and esports
so yes dimitri there actually is a
fairly long list of cosmetic items so
game breaking that they've been banned
in competition the internet's favorite
punching bag league of legends has seen
skins like elementalist lux i blitzcrank
and justicar syndra banned because of
their buggy and altogether difficult to
see animations in the fps world we saw
the ember rise and shattered web player
skins from rainbow six siege and cs go
respectively banned for making you
basically invisible in the right
circumstances turns out being able to
see your opponent in an fps is kind of
important he looks like a [ __ ] flower
pot
how can this be a thing this man is
literally a flower pot you know what the
best part is v2 gave us the money to buy
this skin as a business expense because
it was necessary to win secure the bomb
they paid us money to buy the emperor's
gun
and they didn't give us you know they
just paid the skin for us because it was
necessary to win because everybody else
is using it so is rito about to ban your
favorite phantom skin
well that seems pretty unlikely while
you can see performance increases when
you're feeling good and certain sounds
animations and colors can help your
focus and immersion that's still a long
way from being considered potentially
game breaking especially when the
experience with a particular skin is so
dependent on the individual player but
i'm getting ahead of myself we've
actually got everyone's favorite
professor coming up to give you guys a
bit of a deeper dive on that one so
calling the valor and skins pay to win
is really just hyperbole it's rooted
however loosely in some truth but at the
end of the day should be kept in context
with what an actual game-breaking
cosmetic does to a game i know that
wasn't the super technical deep dive you
guys are used to for me but
what do you want they made me talk about
violence skins if you have any cool tech
related esports stuff you want us to
talk about then you should drop it in
the comments so i can steal it and pitch
it to the team
and maybe i won't have to talk about
attack shooter for a change and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so players are clearly
experiencing some sort of psychological
response when using their favorite skins
but what exactly is going on within our
brains when we go pew pew with our
favorite cosmetics well to help us find
out we reached out to long time friend
of cracked dr madison klarkowski a
professor of computer science at the
university of saskatchewan who
specializes in computer human
interaction she's an og you may remember
her from previous episodes of crack she
suggested that players who feel that
certain skins are pay to win
may be entering a sort of flow state
when using them and experiencing a
heightened sense of focus and in some
cases an increased level in performance
so if paid cosmetics are better at
providing this feedback to a player
whether that's objectively or
subjectively it may be more likely to
induce a flow experience for the player
which then can lead to them feeling like
or actually performing better i say
objectively or subjectively because
people do have different preferences for
different audio cues for different
visual cues so while the default skin
might be you know perfecto for some
people it could be that you know a paid
skin really clicks for other people and
enhancing that user experience which
again might lead to um
lead to the flow experience as well but
what if the skin in question didn't
provide positive feedback for someone
i'm sure many of you have your own list
of pay to lose skins and madison's
concept of flow state can be applied in
the exact same way if a skin's audio
feels too loud or maybe the animations
are too distracting then a player might
not receive the same positive response
that is needed to help them enter their
flow state the arcane sheriff
i swear everyone i've ever seen as a
sheriff including myself
shoots
faster
like because of the animation or
something like they don't wait for the
accuracy to reset uh i think it's the
origin off that has the most disgusting
noise ever every time i pick it up it
makes me not want to shoot the gun
there's some gun skins that you just
pick it up and you're just like oh my
god like this guy couldn't have had any
other skin like for example the glitch
pop vandal i don't know how people use
the glitch pop bundle that gun just too
much movement it's literally all over
the place i just i can't use it i can't
use it so are valorent skins actually
pay to win or in some cases pay to lose
of course not riot always keeps
competitive integrity in mind when
adding new cosmetics to their shooter
but what's really cool is that both the
community and riot themselves can joke
about this together it shows that the
devs really do care a ton about the
player base and the culture that they're
building around the game it's awesome
that we can talk about this like about
like oh our skins pay to win because
like to me that's like a signal of like
we've done exactly what we set out to do
which is like we can joke around about
skins being pay to win because valorent
is so serious about competitive
integrity like we would not be able to
make these jokes if there was any hint
of like unfairness in our game in that
sense so like i love that we can be
tongue-in-cheek about this so first of
all like thank you for talking to us
about this and also i'm super glad that
we can talk about this and while they
might not all be for me this show's
producer keith and our resident valorent
writer niall
are all addicted to valor and skins
they're unlike any other in-game
cosmetic precisely because there's
something for everyone out there whether
you like the loud thud of a prime vandal
the ring of a bell from a reaver or even
the sound of nerf darts
every single player has their own pay to
win skin sometimes if you look good and
you feel good
it's enough to be good so next time make
an effort to grab that brand new weapon
skin off your enemies corpse
because who knows
it might just help you close out that
clutch
if you are interested in acquiring a
riot gun buddy be sure to dm my boy
colton on twitter at the only zoltan
[Laughter]
the only thing i hate more
based